Nói Mung tạo nước cầu có bây tông từ đường xú mừng nước, cần cầu bất ngờ bị sập đại chết năm công nhân,
chương ngày 15 tháng 20.
Quảng Muy Bún dờ, Nói Mung tạo nước xứng năm người đăng đường phía dưới công chính cầu vượt
cầu tốc bên hoa, búng tạo tại sạng phúc để đều trình thí công hệ thống thoát nước.
Lúc này, cần cầu cao muy mết đầu ở đường vung đăng hạc công bây tông, nạn khoảng bây tấn,
tư trên đường xú dưới mừng nước bất ngờ bị lún, nhưng bị hưởng suối.
Mong người ở trên hồ hoàn nhóm công nhân bây dưới thảo trại, bây nhiên một năm công nhân trảy không kiệp bị cân cầu đại chúng.
Tha nhân chứng, lúc cần cầu nghiên tự tự, mong người hồ lớn, có người trảy ngang qua nên thoát,
còn nạn nhân trảy giọc theo suối thị bị đại chúng.
Một công nhân đường trên trảy cầu cũng nhảy xuống kiệp.
Nguyên dân cùng được lượng đăng thí công trên công chường những trong suống cầu năm công nhân dạo ngoài đưa đi cấp vữ,
sông nạn nhân không qua khỏi.